Republican Congressmen and his wife are
accused of spending two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in campaign funds
on themselves and falsifying their
financial records California
representative Duncan hunter and
Margaret hunter were indicted yesterday
charged with describing vacation trips
and dental work as campaign related
Duncan Hunter was one of the first
members of Congress to support the Trump
presidential campaign Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill with details of the
indictment good morning Nancy good
morning there are dozens of charges in
this indictment House Speaker Paul Ryan
called them deeply serious and moved to
strip hunter at least temporarily of his
committee assignments last night
according to the indictment the couple
treated campaign funds essentially like
a personal piggy bank after over drawing
their own accounts 1,100 times over the
course of seven years they allegedly
used campaign cash to pay for utilities
school tuition the theater trips to
Hawaii and Italy and international
travel for nearly a dozen relatives as
well the indictment alleges that hunter
tried to cover up these outlays by
disguising them as campaign expenditures
family dental bills for instance were
recorded as gifts to a charity called
smiles for life at one point his wife
allegedly suggested that a pair of golf
shorts be recorded as a purchase for the
Wounded Warriors Hunter is the second
Republican congressman to be indicted
this month new york republican chris
collins was charged with insider trading
at collins and Hunter were the first two
congressmen to endorse President Trump
during the campaign Hunter's attorney
calls this in tighten n't politically
motivated Hunter himself has showed no
indication that he plans to resign and
it isn't even clear that he has time to
get his name off the ballot in
California before November anyway he and
his wife Nora are scheduled to be
arraigned
San Diego tomorrow all right Nancy on
Capitol Hill thank you so much